I'm ready I'm doing this for me my
family and everybody back home Glen
welcome back thank you
there's now time to see who you will be
facing off against in the very first
battle back competition
I see the smokin send myself oh my god
who the hell is this gonna be
the anticipation is killing me
I am here to play I mean I'm the Messiah
he can walk on water I can walk on lungs
and from the branch when we come from a
school of hard knocks and I got a hard
head I don't like to lose on your mark
get set go
I'm older maybe I got a little more
common sense I'm not going over that
other route I'm going the long way and
not be rushing the way he is because I
really can't fall I can't afford it now
I'm pissed
when the ring comes down thank you big
brother I can use this poison berry on
our samples whoo
Glenn starts going for his boysenberry
that would be devastating
this is it homestretch and I'm like okay
I got this it's right there it's close
I'm getting crazy I got to do this